again it's a lack of accountability well
I had to divorce him we didn't fight
equally and you see the simps co-signing
this behavior and this is the problem
ladies these guys never tell you the
truth they are so deceptive they are
dishonest and Men hear the things we say
they process it and they come to a
conclusion if that makes sense or it
doesn't make sense but most men will not
tell you when it doesn't make sense and
you see her on this podcast and and
they're kind of coddling her they're
saying oh this makes me happy instead of
saying why did you ruin it it's always
everybody else and not themselves and
that's why I argue that really a lot of
these red pill channels Kevin Samuels
fresh and fit they're actually Heroes
because they tell women the truth